[Musik]
die schönsten ist
es ist so
[Musik]
ja
hey meine lieben wir machen heute was
typisch türkisch ist nämlich zugriff der
viele von euch kennen das bestimmt aber
auch nicht nur aus der türkischen küche
das ist eine art eintopf man kann
flüssiger machen muss man aber nicht man
kann es auch als hauptgericht mit der
beilage reich ist muss man aber auch
nicht es geht auch mit brot und die
zutaten diesen sehr überschaubar und die
zeige ich euch jetzt mal direkt gehabt
und zwar benötigen wir kartoffeln die
habe ich in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten
außerdem rinder hat fleisch hier habe
ich zwiebeln die habe ich auch schon
fein gehackt an gewürze salz pfeffer
paprika flocken sind etwas schafft und
edel süßes paprikapulver außerdem
knoblauch und olivenöl
hier habe ich dazu sage ich euch gleich
etwas außer dem mehl und tomaten oder
paprika mark wir kümmern uns zuallererst
das fleisch und köster gibt es ja
wirklich auch ganz viele verschiedene
arten und auch für jedes gericht wird
kräfte anders zubereitet und heute
machen wir kräfte mit natürlich
gewürzten mit knoblauch und mit grütze
hart beißen größe auf türkisch bourgault
ich glaube auch nicht typisch leute
kennen den begriff wohl wird also das
ist glaube ich gängiger als hartweizen
grütze und da gibt es eben viele
unterschiedliche und wir nehmen hier
kiste sagt burth schreibt euch unten in
die infobox damit ihr euch auch nicht
fertig dann kauft und das gebe ich jetzt
auch mit zu vielleicht zusammen mit den
gewürzen und dem knoblauch und danach
richtig schön verkneten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und kennt ihr das jeden tag diese frage
was koche ich heute und wäre im ramadan
ist das erst recht was koche ich heute
dann ist es 30 tage lang fast kaufe ich
nur heute und das ist eben ein sich das
kann man auch mal mehr machen mal ein
bisschen mehr zu bereiten und dann zwei
tage lang es auch richtig lecker
ja ich seh ich auch so lieber mehr
kochen und dann zwei tage davon ist und
die viele gehen davon aus dass wir sehr
sehr viel ist die schönste mittel sich
das ganze mal wieder ist nur richtig man
sollte sich auch nicht von abends nur
weil man den ganzen tag nichts gegessen
hat dann sollte man wirklich das alles
auf eine mahlzeit beschränkt und so
lange bis man es sagt ist dann nicht
mehr meine lieben gibt es jetzt drei
minuten lang geknetet also viel
vorbereitungsarbeit ist es nicht das
einzige was jetzt noch fehlt ist dass
wir das zu kleine kügelchen rollen also
wirklich so klein dass die mit einem
haps im mund sind so gehört sich das für
solo kräfte ja oder so und wenn das
fertig ist und der ganze das ganze
fleisch aufgebraucht ist dann sehen wir
uns wieder
[Musik]
meine kräfte welchen sind fertig ich
habe um die 50 stück raus bekommen und
das nächste das ist jetzt auch ein sehr
wichtiger schritt ist dass wir hier mehr
nehmen und ganz einfach die kräfte
welche damit um manchen und es gebe ich
das einfach drüber und dann schenke ich
meinen schlüssel einfach hin und her und
dann gibt es die von alleine
[Musik]
sollte sind die kräfte welchen fertig
die benutzten wir gleich erst wieder ich
bin hier am herd und hat mir einen
tiefen topf geschnappt habe mein
olivenöl schon rein gegeben und jetzt
nehmen wir uns das tomatenmark und spitz
ministerin an und dann entstehen richtig
schöne röstaromen so und
selbstverständlich kommen auch noch dazu
die werden jetzt auch zwangen main mit
gedünsteten und am besten auf mittlerer
stufe so nach den zwei minuten kommen
die kartoffeln schon mit dazu und wir
haben ja in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten das geniale ist nämlich die
sind nachher gleichzeitig fertig mit
denen kräfte welchen
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt richtig
gut miteinander vermengt und alles hat
sich gut verbunden und eine zutat habe
ich ganz vergessen aber die habt ihr
alle zu hause und zwar kein wasser das
kommt jetzt auch mit dazu und zwar so
dass es ca 2 cm bedeckt ist
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt das ganze einmal
aufkochen lassen das klappt am besten
wenn er den deckel drauf gibt dann geht
das ein bisschen schneller und als
nächstes gehen wir unser kräfte mit dazu
mach das so dass ich hier das
überschüssige mail noch mal so ein
bisschen wegnehmen und dann ganz einfach
frei lägen und dann braucht ihr wirklich
nur noch 15 bis 20 minuten das ganze so
ein bisschen kochen das alles auch
kariert und dann nimmt es auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
ich rühre übrigens alles noch mal gut um
und wenn ihr das mit geschlossenem
deckel kochen das dann verschwinde
natürlich weniger flüssigkeit bei
geöffnetem deckel der verschwindet etwas
flüssigkeit dann ist einfach gucken wer
darf am liebsten mögen
und ganz wichtig ist doch dass wir das
ganze jetzt salzen das gebe ich jetzt
schon mit dazu und natürlich könnt ihr
am ende auch noch mal mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken
also ich habe jetzt doch noch reicht
dazu gekocht ich finde das kann man
wirklich entweder als ganz normal
hauptgang essen ohne alles vielleicht
auch mit ein bisschen brot oder aber
eben mit reis und den hab ich hier
gemacht und ich habe auch schon ein
rezept für reis aber ich verspreche euch
es wird auch einen typisch türkischen
reis geben mit dem nudeln drin das werde
ich euch auch noch das kommt an
demnächst und jetzt wünsche ich euch
ganz ganz viel spaß beim nachkochen ein
schön und guten appetit dann beim
fastenbrechen und ihr könnt auch hier
unten natürlich gerne wieder die infobox
aufklappen die zutaten screen schossen
einkaufen gehen und danach auch also bis
zum nächsten mal auf die sketche
abonnieren nicht vergessen
[Musik]